just about two hours ago did you hear
about this the FBI raided the offices of
President Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cohen now of course out of habit
Cohen offered the agents $130,000 just
keep the whole thing quiet
[Applause]
worked before but he had to form an LLC
first yeah first of all yeah present
Trump is now claiming he had no idea
about the hundred and thirty thousand
dollars paid to silence stormy Daniels
yeah Trump said all I know is it wasn't
enough 145 that's my advice my personal
experience it takes 145 all right I just
lied for 120 all right gotta come up
with that cash of course we're in a
potential trade war with China big story
yeah President Trump tweeted yesterday
that he and China's president gee we'll
always be friends yeah then President Xi
tweeted back new phone who dis
[Music]
they're just like us all right now
listen an NFL player to hear this an NFL
player was arrested for making a bomb
joke at an airport yeah so as no man
it's official NFL players have now been
arrested for every single type of crime
that was the last one
vomiting airport was the last one yeah
unbelievable
talking a snake into a soos oh okay that
didn't come out right I knew what I
wanted to say it just you know I know
your mouth betrayed you it was really
the rum before the show today at Bill
Cosby's new trial a woman protested
topless in order to make Bill Cosby feel
uncomfortable
legal experts are describing the effort
as a failure I was good enough was just
what I needed new Facebook founder of
Atari today Facebook founder Mark
Zuckerberg met privately with members of
Congress before his scheduled hearings
he wanted to talk to a lot of them
privately first he told each member of
Congress remember I know your browser
history
via Facebook Facebook has announced a
way for users to unsend messages yes all
you have to do is go to the message
center and click the button marked I was
drunk
[Applause]
you